.
GENERAL KELLOGG, THANKS FOR YOUR
ANALYSIS.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU GENERAL,
JOHN, LET'S BRING IN DANA
PERINO, ON SET.
>> IT WAS SO CONFUSING.
>> Sandra: IT IS CONFUSING.
WATCHING THE MOTORCADE PULL OUT,
AND YOU SAW THE FRUSTRATION FROM
THE REPORTERS IN THE ROOM,
SAYING WAIT A SECOND, ONLY 6 OR
7 GOT QUESTIONS, AND THERE WERE
21 IN THE ROOM, AND LATE AND HAD
TO LEAVE BUT JUST PUSHED UP THE
NEWS CONFERENCE 90 MINUTES FROM
THE 3:00 EASTERN TIME PLANNED
NEWS CONFERENCE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU MAKE
ANYTHING UP THAT.
THE --
>> I USED TO WORK FOR A
PRESIDENT WHO LIKED TO GET
THINGS DONE EARLY AND IF YOU
WERE NOT EARLY YOU WERE LATE.
IT'S NOT TYPICAL WITH THIS
PRESIDENT.
IT COULD BE THAT THEY HAD ENOUGH
AGREEMENT AND THAT EVERYTHING
THEY NEEDED TO DO IN THE MEETING
WAS EARLY, FINE.
HE DID NOT TAKE ENOUGH
QUESTIONS.
THE REPORTERS HAVE GONE ALL THE
WAY OVER THERE.
THEY ARE SITTING THERE WAITING,
THEY HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE ANSWERS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN LESS THAN WHAT
ZELENSKYY OR WE WERE WANTING, HE
WAS HAVING A PRETTY GOOD PRESS
CONFERENCE.
WHY NOT KEEP GOING, BECAUSE
THERE WAS ENOUGH HUNGER IN THE
ROOM HE COULD HAVE CONTINUED TO
ANSWER.
HE WAS PRETTY SHARP.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I WOULD NOT
HAVE ANSWERED THE 2024 ELECTION
THE WAY HE DID, I WOULD NOT HAVE
DONE THAT ON FOREIGN SOIL.
I'M HONORED TO BE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, 2024 IS A
LONG WAY AWAY, DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT TODAY'S SUBJECT.
I WOULD NEVER HAVE DONE THAT ON
FOREIGN SOIL.
>> John: LONGER HE TAKES
QUESTIONS THE CHANCE ONE DOES
NOT COME OUT OF HIS MOUTH AS IT
SHOULD, THE FAMOUS PRESS
CONFERENCE NOT TOO LONG AGO HE
STARTED TAKING QUESTION AFTER
QUESTION AFTER QUESTION AND
FINALLY SAID WELL, IF IT'S A
SMALL INCURSION --
>> MINOR INCURSION.
>> John: AND I THINK PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS WERE VERY PUBLIC.
IN TERMS OF THIS ARGUMENT THAT
HAS BEEN MADE BY THE PRESIDENT'S
CRITICS THAT HE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE PLAYING TO WIN HERE WITH
UKRAINE.
WHAT SIGNAL DO YOU THINK HE SENT
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN AND TO UKRAINE
ON THAT FRONT?
>> CAN I SAY THAT I DON'T THINK
IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THIS MORNING?
I MEAN, DID VLADIMIR PUTIN NEED
TO HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT 20
TIMES THAT NATO HAS NEVER BEEN
AS UNITED?
I THINK WE ALL SEE THAT.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
WE ARE HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT NEW.
I HAVE TO IMAGINE THERE HAS TO
BE SOME SORT OF BACK CHANNEL
COMMUNICATION TO ZELENSKYY SO HE
GETS A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THERE WERE A COUPLE THINGS HE
SAID THAT I THINK WERE WORTH IT.
AND PUTIN WOULD TAKE NOTICE OF
THIS, THE PRESIDENT WAS
DEFINITIVE THAT PUTIN AND RUSSIA
SHOULD NOT BE IN THE G20, AND
PUTIN HAD BUILT THE ECONOMY TO
THE POINT HE COULD BE A PART OF
THE G20 AND NO MORE.
AND THAT -- OR AT LEAST IF THE
OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T AGREE TO
IT, SAID UKRAINE SHOULD JOIN AS
WELL, WHICH MAKES THE G20 POINT
LESS.
SO I THINK THERE WAS A LITTLE
NEWS THERE AND DEFINITIVE ON
THAT POINT.
>> Sandra: HE WAS ASKED WHETHER
OR NOT RUSSIA NEEDS TO BE
REMOVED, DEFINITIVELY YES, HE
FEELS THAT, DEPENDING ON THE
G20.
FOOD SHORTAGES, IT'S GOING TO BE
REAL SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN, AND
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH FACT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE ENERGY, BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE GRAINS THAT
FEED THE WORLD, IT'S GOING TO BE
A REAL STRUGGLE.
>> WHEN I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH
YOU IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS, THERE
ARE REAL NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS TO HUNGER AROUND
THE WORLD.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE ARAB SPRING,
A LOT OF PEOPLE MIGHT REMEMBER
AND SAY OH, ABOUT TWITTER,
RIGHT?
NO, THE WHEAT PRICES HAVE GONE
UP SO MUCH.
AND THERE WAS SO MUCH
FRUSTRATION.
WHEN YOU HAVE PROBLEMS LIKE FOOD
COSTS GOING UP THIS MUCH, YOU
WILL HAVE UPRISINGS.
IT LEADS TO IMMIGRATION AND ALSO
FAMINE AND STARVATION.
NOT ONLY THE GRAIN IS A HUGE
PROBLEM BUT FARMERS GET THEIR
FERTILIZER FROM RUSSIA.
SO OUR FARMERS ARE ABOUT TO DO
THEIR PLANTINGS IN THE NEXT FOUR
WEEKS.
IF THEY DON'T GET ENOUGH
FERTILIZER WE WILL NOT HAVE
ENOUGH FOOD HERE EITHER.
IT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
APPARENTLY NATO HAS TALKED ABOUT
IT AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
EVERYONE HAS TO THINK ABOUT, NOT
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE FOOD, BUT A NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATION AS WELL.
>> John: WHAT ABOUT THIS NONRED
LINE RED LINE THE PRESIDENT DREW
WITH CHEMICAL WEAPONS, IT WOULD
TRIGGER A RESPONSE, THE RESPONSE
WOULD BE MEASURED BY WHATEVER
THE ATTACK WAS AND SAID THERE
WOULD BE A RESPONSE IN KIND.
I'M NOT SURE THAT IN KIND WERE
THE WORDS THAT HE WAS LOOKING
FOR, BECAUSE A CHEMICAL RESPONSE
IN KIND WOULD BE A CHEMICAL
RESPONSE AND WE ARE NOT ABOUT TO
DO THAT.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF WHAT HE
SAID THERE?
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS TAKEN ON THE CRITICISM
THE PRESIDENT HAS RULED OUT TOO
MANY THINGS HE WILL NOT DO, AND
WHY NOT LEAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
MYSTERY.
BUT THEN AS YOU JUST DESCRIBED
THE ANSWER, IT DOES SEEM A
LITTLE MORE MUDDLED.
IF IT'S THIS, THAT, AND TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION, INSTEAD OF
JUST SAYING WE'LL LET YOU KNOW
BUT WE ARE ON TO YOU.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO DESCRIBE
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
DO.
AND YOU CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T DRAW
A RED LINE IF YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO ADHERE TO IT AS WE SAW IN
SYRIA BACK IN 2012.
2014, EXCUSE ME.
>> Sandra: A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT COULD DO TO
CHANGE THE CURRENT PERCEPTION OF
THE CURRENT SITTING U.S.
PRESIDENT ON THE WORLD STAGE.
I BELIEVE THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL WROTE ABOUT THIS AS WE
WERE WORKING OUR WAY INTO THE
WEEK, ANTICIPATING THE
PRESIDENT'S ARRIVAL AND VISIT
THERE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
SAID OR DID ANYTHING ON THE
GLOBAL STAGE JUST NOW TO CHANGE
THE WAY THE WORLD SEES THIS
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW, I THINK IT'S
VERY GOOD HE WENT, GOOD THEY HAD
A FACE-TO-FACE MEETING AND A LOT
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS IN
ANY MEETING HAVE BEEN BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS, SO MAYBE WE'LL
HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT.
FIRST TIME HE HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET THE NEW PRIME MINISTER OF
JAPAN, A VERY IMPORTANT
ALLIANCE.
SO NOW IN THE SORT OF POST
COVIDISH WORLD, THE FACT HE'S HE
IS THERE, THE FACT HE MADE
STATEMENTS, MANY OF THE ANSWERS
WERE PRETTY SHARP AND HE SEEMED
LIKE HE HAD ENERGY AND SO I
WOULD SAY NET PLUS SO FAR.
>> Sandra: INTERESTING.
DA